[Música]
noticias de salud con romero y vamos a
comenzar porque la pandemia de kobe 19
sigue presente en el mundo aunque cada
vez sabemos más sobre el virus cuáles
son las últimas novedades y le pregunto
a usted más buenos días angela pues
efectivamente en esta sección nos toca
recordar por suerte por fortuna que
seguimos en una pandemia y así vamos a
ir actualizando por ejemplo los últimos
informes publicados en las últimas
semanas hablamos de un estudio sobre la
inventiva de un estudio sobre la
diabetes y el comité 19 y para entender
mejor las implicaciones de todas estas
noticias como siempre estamos con el
doctor carlos pérez médico infectólogo
de la universidad nacional de colombia
doctor buenos días y bienvenidos de
nuevo al programa hablamos de la
ivermectina es un medicamento que pues
se dijo que era una oportunidad para
tratar el 19 pero que sin embargo pues
se ha demostrado que no funciona
entonces es una estudio el primer
estudio a gran escala que se ha
publicado en brasil más de 1.300
personas han participado en este estudio
y se ha demostrado de nuevo pues que no
tienen contra el hobbit 19
además
este estudio es muy importante porque
durante mucho tiempo e incluso por
gobiernos como el gobierno brasilero se
usó la ivermectina como parte de los
tratamientos antivirales y se fundamentó
en un principio es que en la ivermectina
en estudios in vitro es decir en
estudios de laboratorio tenía acción
antiviral es decir que en una prueba de
laboratorio y eso se quiso extrapolar a
las poblaciones dando medicamentos y
siendo este un antiparasitario que tenía
ese efecto que se había documentado en
vitro se pensó que tenga un tratamiento
actividad que eso se ha descartado desde
desde hace mucho tiempo sin embargo este
estudio que mencionas es un estudio que
es contundente es decir que no produce
ningún beneficio y que nunca se debía
tener como una alternativa terapéutica
la grenetina en estos casos dejar un
saludo leal ángela gómez si quisieran
preguntarle qué tratamientos que si
funcionan están actualmente disponibles
para kobe 19
angela buenos días mira uno de los
estudios que muestran es dos
medicamentos muy interesantes que son
antivirales directos conocíamos uno que
deben decidir que se utiliza en medios
hospitalarios pero tenemos dos
medicamentos para usar en casa o
ambulatorios como es el pax low o el mur
tiran navid estos medicamentos orales
sirven para el tratamiento tenemos otras
alternativas como anticuerpos anti
monoclonales que sirven para poblaciones
inmunosuprimidas y medicamentos que
controlan la inflamación como el bar así
tímido en escenarios hospitalarios hoy
aquí la tenemos varios esquemas de
tratamiento que hacen que los pacientes
con colitis severo tengan opciones
terapéuticas y que reducen efectivamente
la mortalidad y la gravedad de esta
enfermedad
gracias por esas aclaraciones porque
también a veces pues se difunde una
información sobre la ivermectina que es
falsa y debemos saber todos pues cuáles
son los tratamientos que si están
recomendados contra el commit 19 pero
pasemos a otro estudio que publicó the
lancet sobre el riesgo de diabetes y el
commit 19 se vio analizando los datos
miles de personas que el riesgo de
diabetes crecía después de una infección
de kobe 19 incluso si la infección era
leve a que se puede dar esta relación
hay una relación que existe en la
diabetes tipo 2
esta diabetes se ha asociado
tradicionalmente a infecciones que
pueden producir inflamación en los
islotes pancreáticos que reducen o dañan
el bigote pancreático y disminuye la
capacidad de producir insulina el coi
también hace parte de esta de estas
enfermedades que pudieran hacer este año
a nivel pancreático y aún incrementa el
riesgo de diabetes como ya se mostró en
el estudio pues esto es algo preocupante
creo que nosotros tenemos un capítulo
muy largo es el post kobe que hasta
ahora estamos conociendo y este
incremento de la diabetes en pacientes
que ha tenido kobe pues nos hace que
monitorice moss a los pacientes que
tengan con colts -con glicemias con
examen médicos para poder determinar
intervenir tempranamente la diabetes que
también es una enfermedad controlable y
que tenemos alternativas para manejo y
con tanta gente contagiada de comida a
largo plazo que implica este crecimiento
en los casos de diabetes
y lo que llamamos el lonko o lo que casa
es lo que estamos describiendo una parte
es esto de la diabetes tenemos otros que
son las alteraciones neurológicas otras
las alteraciones en la enfermedad mental
y son un gran número y variado de
complicaciones que no se ven en todas
las poblaciones en algún segmento de la
población pero que nos enseñan que el
coi no es inocuo de ahí que todavía hay
personas angela que no se han vacunado
el llamados a vacunarse porque hay que
prevenir esta enfermedad y si se tiene
la enfermedad consultar al médico para
darle tratamiento efectivo las
complicaciones como diabetes
neurológicas cardiacas y pulmonares y
renales del cobach estamos entendiendo
las hasta ahora y pasar a un par de años
para que entendamos mejor qué hacer con
ellos doctor está haciendo un llamado a
la vacunación eeuu precisamente aprobó
recientemente la segunda dosis de
refuerzo en las vacunas contra él como
19 qué opinión le merece esta decisión
desde que establecimos la vacunación
sabemos que nos va a ser para toda la
vida y con el pasar del tiempo se va a
perder la inmunidad esta aprobación de
este refuerzo en estados unidos del
segundo refuerzo es para población mayor
de 50 años o personas que han perdido la
inmunidad por medicamentos o por
enfermedades de base es muy probable que
nosotros como población en el segundo
semestre
necesitemos una segunda unas dosis
adicionales de la vacuna y que
necesitamos mejores formulaciones de la
vacuna para dar una inmunidad más
prolongada por ahora llamar a los que no
sean vacunados que se vacunen a los que
tienen esquema completo que se refuercen
y estar atentos para podernos inmunizar
todos y prevenir y salir de esta
enfermedad en este año doctora mar
gracias a ustedes por todas las
aclaraciones y mañana habrá más
actualizaciones vamos ahora con nuestro